today we're happy to have uh having Jose
tell us about Simon versus Market
very much
so this is a joint it's about three
different works with each one the author
is being a subset of the people here
three different subsets so it's Ahmed
Shahar
Ben who's here
and Morgan and also xiaoming who was an
undergrad at McGill
um okay so what is
this talk about it's about some
different Notions of rank that turn out
to be
important in many different areas
first Define these different Notions of
rank and then we'll see the motivation
behind them
so let's say what is first what is real
rank of a matrix well one way to view
the rank of a matrix is
you want let's say you have a plus one
minus one matrix it's n by n
you want to look at the rank is the
smallest Dimension d
where you can find vectors
X1 up to xn one for each row in Rd and
one one up to i m one for each column
in Rd so that the inner product of x i y
j is whatever is the IJ entry of the
Matrix right so in terms of like
factorization the X's correspond to the
rows of the
first tall Matrix that you have in the
factorization and Y correspond to The
Columns of the tall Matrix this at The
Matrix
so let's say you're you're bored with
this definition and you just want to
change it somehow so there are two
things to play with right one is this
condition that vectors live in Rd and
one is this condition that things are
equal so let's first try to alter the
green condition so how can one change
that to make it more relaxed
well you can just say well I just want
the products of these
to be some number between one up to
whatever constant let's say 10 or
something
okay so this is supposed to be tilled
but I don't know why it's not fully
showing here so maybe I'll
improve later but um so here it was this
product has been one and one right so
I'm just changing this side to be some
Alpha
so this is called approximate rank
another even you can further relax it to
say well Alpha is infinity
and this is called now sign rank I could
have put Infinity here
and so you just want to preserve the
signs so here I could have put zero it
wouldn't make anything because I could
just scale the vectors right
and let's say sine if
zero is plus one so if this was Zero I
consider that to be a plus one in The
Matrix
okay so that's three different
definitions
um we can now try to relax in the other
dimension relax the red requirements
so what does that correspond to well a
natural condition
instead of looking at the dimension of
the vectors is to say the vectors can
live in whatever Dimension I don't care
so it's n plus n Vector so let's say
this is our n plus m
but I require that the length of this
vectors is short so I
want to find the smallest L where I can
find these vectors where for every i j
is a product of L2 Norm of these vectors
is at most power why is it naturally
constrained the product of the Norms
rather than
good it doesn't make a difference right
because if it was
individually you could just go back and
forth between the maximum of all X I's
and xjs and the product you'll just lose
squared
right
because I can just scale one side would
it doesn't matter right because I do
yeah but losing this way doesn't bother
you you're able to hear everything is
about poly relations so it doesn't
really make yeah make any difference
actually do I even lose any Square
and
yeah
yes so in the sign rank if aij is zero
what happens so it's let's say you I
mean the definition to be zero here and
it is zero the sine of zero is plus
let's say
let's say zero times one equals one
right it doesn't make any let's say
You're really uncomfortable with that
well you want to never get zero because
that might be weird you can always bump
the dimension by one extra Dimension to
say you can never get zero right it just
makes it make sure none of these inner
products are zero if you have one extra
Dimension just put some like infinite
testimony in the extra dimension for
everybody
foreign
right that would be a different
definition of sine rank which I'm not
sure if it's equivalent
is
right so the benefit of this gamma to
and the relaxation as is in it's in
computer right because you can write to
some semi-definite programming this
would be the optimal value right
rank is easily computable it's a lucky
thing but these two things are hard to
compute and in fact it's it's a result
of am I might be here and coparti we
show that this is even to decide if this
is three or not it's NP hard inside is
even harder than NPR but
but um
but here the good thing about these type
of norms is that it's computable easily
um okay so is the definition gamma too
non-clear
okay so let's now try to in this
direction
make it relaxed
so gamma to tailed again with some
approximation Factor Alpha is I just now
require this to be true instead of exact
equality
and I can further again relax it to say
that gamma to Infinity is I just want to
every inner product to be every product
here to be at least one
right
so the template The Meta question in
this talk that I'll be talking about
has the following template I'm picking
one of these Norms one of these
parameters and I'm saying if that
parameter is small how large can the
other parameter be okay
so there are six parameters and
this question there you get six times
five thirty questions
um
many of them are trivial so we're we'll
be talking about non-trivial some of the
non-trivial ones and even still not all
of them are resolved
but turns out that this question has
different interpretations in many
different areas and
it's relates to a lot of different maths
okay so let's just take an example first
so this is the identity Matrix
correspond to the equality function
so the rank is in
the approximate rank of this that
anybody has a guess
who hasn't seen it
so let's say approx by approximate right
let's say now from now on I have my
Alpha
parameter is some like 10 or whatever it
doesn't matter so it's an absolute
constant
so this is a result of Alon that shows
the approximal rank of identity is log n
okay
and now what about sign rank
what do you guess for the sign rank so
do you have any intuition good I'll give
you an intuition for a second but
without intuition any wild guesses
wow okay that's a good intuition okay so
um so yeah what would be some intuition
for sign rank
so how would you think about the sign
rank of a matrix let's say again you
have this plus minus patterns
so I want to pick for each row pick an X
like for so X will respond to a
particular row y correspond to a
particular column
and I want if it's positive if this plus
I want this to be positive right in
other words if you think of this y as
the normal Vector to this hyperplane
then I just want this x to be on the
positive side of this height this half
space that's defined by this hyper plane
right so basically for each column I can
just say I have these half spaces and I
and I'm just checking inclusion I'm am I
on this side of the half space on the
other side
and these have spaces are homogeneous
but let's just say I relax the
requirement to be just arbitrary
Alpha and half spaces because if I get
an arrangement like this then I can add
one extra Dimension to make everybody we
can watching yes again
so now you can think of this as just
some incidence Matrix of this uh
inclusion problem right you have for
each row you have a point in Rd and for
each column you have a half space
and you put a plus if row if the point
is in the half space or if it's put
minus if it's outside of the half space
and again let's say I'm not on the half
space exactly or if I'm on it let's just
set say put that a plus right so this is
a closed set so
okay so with this intuition can you have
an arrangement of point hyperplanes or
have spaces for for equality function
for identity
so here's the simple Arrangement just
put
your for rows just put them like this
okay now the half spaces each point has
a unique half space that only there I'm
Plus on the diagonal right and everyone
else must be minus so I mean this is the
separator
so this is the half space for this point
that's only separates out this point
right so for each
point I get this corresponding half
space for the column the same column
so this is in two dimensions
but again these are not homogeneous and
the definition I required homogeneity so
I can just increase the one extra
Dimension to make everybody pass through
zero
so the sine rank is three
okay so what is the gamma two Norm of
identity
another one to make to waste too much
time so I'll just say it immediately
it's one so gamma 2 number is one and
everybody else is smaller because it's
also one and also you have to be at
least one right
new things change if I require symmetry
like if I if I require this X and Y like
x i equals one more good so that's a
very different question right it's this
is generally a bipartite type of
question and if I require to pick the
same Vector for the row and the same
column it's a different question like in
that case like
all minus would be hard right because
that corresponds to just picking a bunch
of points everybody's or less than Ortho
has negative correlation right so this
is here you want to really capture
complexity in a way that this nice these
basic objects like that all one or this
sort of thing is easy right
foreign
okay so instead of juggling with six
parameters from now on I'll only focus
until foreseeable future on these two
sunrise and Delta Infinity but the land
will talk about the other problems so
it's the intuition here that's in
communication like the music randomized
and uh we'll get into that too much
connection but for now there's no
Communications
um Okay so
so what do let me just motivate sound
rank a little bit so cyan turns out to
be a crucial parameter in learning
theory so in learning theory is called
Dimension complexity and it's used to
prove lower bounds on learning problems
and also prove obtain algorithms in fact
as an example the best known learning
algorithm for DNS due to cliveness
server deal is by obtaining a strong
upper Bond on sine rank of DNS
okay so I won't get additional details
of any of this I'm just casually
throwing some keywords about connections
with sound rank in different areas so
that's in learning theory in
communication complexity it's a crucial
concept why because it turns out that a
lot of sign rank is exactly
this concept unbounded error
communication complexity of a
so this is a model where you look at
randomized communication complexity but
you just want to beat the pure random
guess which has error half you just want
to have error at strictly less than half
I'm not going to Define communication
complexity because if you don't know it
it doesn't matter for the motivation and
everything will be found without the
story of communication complexity but if
you know it it's just extra motivation
um so this is a plus minus one here but
it doesn't matter
so this is a result of paturi summoning
Yeah so basically this connection makes
it highly relevant in communication
complexity right because this is
this model is important when people want
to understand its relation to different
models of communication
so there's a communication velocity and
circle lower bound is also important
because you can use it to prove lower
bound on some certain types of circuits
for example because this is ridiculously
simple type of circuits thresholds of
majority whatever that means it's like a
two layer circuit uh
proving lower bound on CY rank implies
proving lower Bonds on
these type of circuits so this is
one application is circuit complexity
also it's a highly relevant parameter
and semi-object-brike community so with
semi-algebraic graphs are basically
sound rank becomes one of the most
important parameters in fact one of the
very important open question in the area
is that
semi-algebraic graphs of bounded
complexity are precisely those that have
bounded cymark
so what would sound like it was all it
was all these Arrangements of incidents
of half spaces and points you can
generalize that right you can just say
well instead of half spaces I can for
each column I could have some like
semi-algebraic set which is like a
intercession with a bunch of polynomial
inequalities
and
look at the incidence of Matrix of that
right and an important question is
does this if this is bounded complexity
like all the degrees and the dimensions
of the polynomials are bounded can you
say that it's actually you can just
change everybody to be half space and by
slight bump in the dimension
so it's an important open question okay
now let's move on to gamma 2 Infinity
Norm
so this is this is called margin
complexity in machine learning it's an
extremely important parameter learning
theory why because in many learning
problems
when you try to solve it you could think
of it as a plus minus Matrix
and sign rank fine it gives a good upper
Bound for learning but sometimes cyan
could be really large could be the
biggest and if sometimes n is infinity
so it's just infinite Dimension it
doesn't make sense like you have all
this cursive dimensionality stuff so if
Dimension is high the learning task
becomes very difficult however if I
guarantee you that
this gamma to Infinity of your concept
class or the Matrix you define is
bounded then there is this simple
algorithm called support Vector machines
that just its sample complexity is only
squared of the gamma to Infinity Norm
s regardless of how if it's even
infinite dimensional it doesn't matter
right
so a good sub part of learning theory is
about obtaining good balance for gamma
to infinity and all the different
problems
realistic and machine learning and
communication complexity
it's highly relevant because turns out
that gamma to Infinity is just basically
equivalent to this notion called
discrepancy
like one divided by discrepancy
the description is a number between zero
and one and
um
so this proof is uses growth indic
inequality basically and some Minimax
duality
so because of this connection it's
highly relevant in communication
complexity in fact it turns out that
this log of this gamma to Infinity
normal log of this is a lower Bond a
randomized communication complexity in
fact one of the strongest lower ones we
know
and here also you can put gamma to
Infinity itself so in the constant
regime it becomes an equivalent notion
notion with randomized communication
okay so this discrepancy is not the same
thing as combinatorial discrepancy in in
like combinatorics people when like look
at the Matrix
they put uniform Distribution on The
Matrix and they want to say every set is
very good so this you want your Matrix
to be Epsilon regular and this is the
same already sense right but here
I'm looking at
just finding one distribution
that is small so I want to find a
distribution on the entries of the
Matrix under that distribution I have a
local relation with every year rectangle
like every rectangle becomes like
balance
or almost balanced
anyway I won't describe discrepancy
because it's just we're going to work
with gamma to Infinity number
um okay so so now the question the first
question that I'll be talking about is
the following
it's a natural question if sign rank is
very small is it possible like how large
can gamma to Infinity be
okay you obtain some good upper bounds
on gamma to Infinity if the sign rank is
small or not
there was a lot of previous work on this
question
and the best known separation was
um Matrix that has
log log of n so again it's a number
between 1 up to n
and it's gamma to Infinity is at least
polyan
okay
um on the other hand also one can show
that if the sign rank is 2
then this can be only poly log cannot be
bigger than polylog
um
Okay so
but on the other hand there's also some
positive evidence that might say one
could might this might be the best
separation that could happen right
because why because
gamma 2 Norm
like not the approximate just gamma to
exact gamma to Norm for bounded entry
matrices is at most square root of rhyme
so
this also the same thing for approximate
gamma turn around and this is an
material fact basically this follows
some John's theorem from convex geometry
so given that this is true for gamma 2
and approximate gamma 2 1 might think
that maybe some things similar can be
done if you look at the infinity version
so gamma 2 Infinity cannot be maybe two
larger if sine rank is constant let's
say but it so but we showed a few years
ago that this is not the case so
basically we showed that
sign rank Two Fine sine Rank 2 is cannot
be too big gamma 2 but there is a matrix
of sine I have only three whose gamma
2normal is essentially the biggest
possible like it's polygon
and the Matrix is
so I won't describe the probability I'll
just just say what the construction is
it's
an actual construction I'm basically
just looking at integer in a product so
I'm just looking at numbers so each row
corresponds to three vectors three
numbers all of these are between minus n
and n
and uh
same for each column
and for the corresponding entry in The
Matrix I'm putting plus if the inner
product
is
non-negative and put minus if it's
negative
okay so I guess the size of the Matrix
is
actually n cubed instead of but it's
probably n so it doesn't matter
so this result was yeah basically gamma
to Infinity normal this is at least
polyan
and I won't describe the proof but the
proof with a lot of technical Fourier
analysis over zp
we work with this notion of discrepancy
instead of gamma to infinity and the
point is that you want to carefully
choose a smart distribution under which
every rectangle is roughly balanced okay
so you have to first shoot find a good
distribution and then prove that the
distribution has some nice it has this
nice regularity condition
okay so now let me switch to
the other direction of the question
so I won't describe pros and and only I
will describe a detail of one one cute
one line proof for this question but
other than that I will skip over the
details of other products
okay so what's the second question you
can just ask Philip the question right
now now I'm asking if gamma 2 Infinity
is small how large can Sun rank be
okay so every anybody has intuition for
this
so why what my why one might hope the
sign rank shouldn't be too big
it's because of dimensionality reduction
right so there is this result
we saw that sign rank is always upper
bounded by log of the size of the Matrix
times poly of the gamma to Infinity
so any ideas why this might be true
so there you apply this thing called
Johnson Linden Strauss Lemma right which
tells you you can if you have this
arrangement of points you can always
projects jump down to a login
dimensional space where you don't change
the inner product by more than some
Epsilon so Epsilon Epsilon parameter
I'll be working with here is one divided
by gamma to Infinity
and the guarantee of Johnson is that
this is going to be the dimension
okay
they just throw just apply that and that
brings the dimension to login
and so the question that was asked by
Millennials right this in this work
right
they asked whether this login term is
necessary right because maybe here
because I have this extra condition of
gamma 2 Norm is constant or like it's
big sorry it's small maybe I can do
something smarter than Donald straws
what can is it possible to just get if
this login dependency over from
the dependency
because Johnson describes about every
possible collection of points here you
look at these two sets of points that
every inner pairwise in the product
somebody from here and somebody from
here
if you normalize the points they're at
least something if you have a lower
bound on the
normalizing the product
so
this is in its entirety it's still open
the question but in this work with Hamad
and Xiang mang we showed that this
long-term login term is actually
necessary if you
just allow partial matrices
so I'll describe that in a second
it's we basically construct a matrix
that this is typed
so so what is
but before getting to that okay so let
me just tell you the equivalent story in
communication complexity and if you
don't know communication complexity it
doesn't matter you just ignore these
slides
um
so what is numeral it's this famous
result in communication complexity that
says so now to make things meaningful
I'm looking at the my Matrix to be to
the End by to the end
Newman's Lamar says that founded error
public Randomness communication
complexity
can upper bound private Randomness
communication complexity at this
overhead of login right
and this immediately implies that this
notion that I described before unbounded
error communication complexity in this
private model is at most public
plus this additive term login
it's known that this is tight just again
again because of the elements example
identity equality right because
this one is constant there but
the approximate rank implies that this
is at least login
so a natural question to ask is what
about this weaker deduction is this
tight
what about the relationship between this
unbounded error private model
compared to the public bounded
Okay so
potentially this could have been just an
additive term
okay
so yeah this this is the question we
want to save this additive login term is
necessary and equivalent to what I said
before
or
we basically yeah we say that this login
term isn't necessary
so now I'll just tell you what's the
construction and say something about the
proof so the construction is not a total
matrix it's a partial Matrix so what do
I mean by a partial matrix it's a plus
one minus one Matrix
but some of the entries are stars so
it's a plus minus one star Matrix now
what is what are the definitions of sine
Rank and Gamma 2norm and all that
it's the exact same as before except
when I check the conditions where for
the stars I just don't require those
don't have the requirements so I don't
have the requirement in the length of
the vectors
or if the inner the sign of the inner
product is the same as what's here or
whatever because this is all right just
ignore those Stars
so every everything is well defined
still
okay so this now we what do we show is
that
pick an arbitrary Epsilon
so gamma 2 is its minimum is again one
saying you can even get arbitrarily
close to one
there is a matrix that's
its sign rank is basically what's just
guaranteed by the Johnson Linden Strauss
so it sound rank is at least Epsilon
times n
and this is also types it's Epsilon and
it also is an upper bound
so up till this large Factory retired
Jordan seems I'm just confused by the
Okay so
will be inspired these
minimize the work
compares the vector type of place that
satisfy just these constraints not
always exactly so why could you take
whatever vectors in our Infinity realize
that's what I that's what we do right
what this is about first of all the way
I wrote it it's an N is
it's n it's not infinity and the
dependency question is about dependency
on the size of the Matrix but you're
looking at infinite version of it I'll
get to that in a second okay basically
reduce the problem to this infinite
version yeah there was another question
foreign
okay so what is the construction one can
look at
the one that Jordan described but that
was the infinite version so let's first
talk about the finite version of that so
what's the construction is this Gap in a
product so I'm looking at all vectors in
this Cube that are normalized to have
Norm 1 exactly and I Define this Matrix
just by the inner product is at least
one minus Epsilon think of Epsilon to be
some small constant let's say a quarter
or something
and if it's less than minus of that I
put minus and if it's between I put star
okay
so the claim is that the
sign rank of this is Epsilon and roughly
okay
so how do we prove this we
look at this continuous version so what
do I look at I look at all units points
on the sphere
and Define this Matrix this infinite by
SN minus 1 by SN minus 1 Matrix where I
again
if exactly same exactly the same thing
right
so what do I claim about this the claim
is that
before the claim this is also a highly
relevant concept again in machine
learning people call it half spaces with
margin and it's uh
yeah so it's the properties this class
is very important
but the claim that we have is that
no matter how Epsilon is small as long
as it's not zero
and for any answer for any end and any
Epsilon the soundtrack is full so this
is naturally n dimensional and I'm
saying you cannot even decrease the
dimension by anything
okay
so potentially I mean if Epsilon maybe
depending on N could get really close to
zero one might hope to do something
smart and reduce the dimension
but you'll see that it's not true so
I'll give you the proof of this
a little bit of the proof not all of it
okay
so basically if this after resolving
this as the main level then we get the
the Gap in a product version as well
okay so what is the proof of this main
Lemma it's basically just a one-line
application of worship ulam theorem so
parts of ulam theorem has 58 equivalent
formulations but the one we're working
with is the following
so what does it say it says if you have
a continuous map from sphere to one
lower dimension
and there's always this antipital pair
so there's always a point
on the sphere and it's there's a
reflection so that they're both mapped
to the same thing
okay
so we're going to use this
how can we use this to prove the the
bound
this was the claim
so
The Matrix again the roses and the
columns The Matrix corresponds to points
here on the CR right and let's say
somebody claims that the dimension of
this is less than n
the sign rank so there must be a smart
choice of mapping the rows using some
map F to one lower Dimension and map the
Y's using some other map G to
the same lower dimension so that it
preserves the sign of the inner products
okay so two things here were positively
correlated in the maps they have to be
positively correlated
so why is this
implying what we want so let's say for a
second that
suppose that the maps are continuous so
in the definition sign right there is no
need for the maps to be continuous I
mean it could be any crazy map Zone well
pathological map that one could find
possibly but here let's just say it's
continuous so I can just without worry
apply more so ulam so what
do I do so let's even just say only f is
continuous it doesn't matter so let's
say f is a continuous map
therefore there must be this antipital
pair
and let's say oh this is one minus
Epsilon so let's say this was your
threshold
so pick a pair X so X was X is
determined by Boards of column so this
is given to you just pick an arbitrary
UI that's really close to X so the inner
product
is so big that it has to be positive in
The Matrix
and borso coulomb says after you mapped
minus X is also mapped to the same thing
but in a product of minus x with Y has
to have is negative right The Matrix has
to be negative
right so on one hand I know that this is
true because the maps are good
on the other hand
I know that
also because of this
and because of worship ulam
the
F of minus X is the same as f of x
so it must be the same thing as this one
but this was positive
although this I should have chosen this
to be negative right because it's the
corresponding thing is negative
oh sorry this should be a minus X here
okay but then this this just means
you're violating the sign pattern
between minus X and that's y right
so this is working in the case that the
maps are continuous
if the maps are not continuous you just
have to continualize them carefully so I
if the maps are not continuous I look at
some continuation of them
that at what cost well I might mess up
some of the inner product science it's
fine but I'm just saying I might just
work with another threshold that's
slightly bigger than gamma after the
Conti then I'll get the continuous map
with some gamma Prime that's satisfying
all the conditions
okay so I that's it I want to describe
the the Gap timing version of this but
you basically just reduce this problem
to the Gap hammock so in a way that if
Gap Hamming had extremely small sign
rank or sorry Gap in a product so the
the discrete version then it would imply
that this also will have sound right
less than n yeah
so the continuous okay
so you just have the map f and g
and you this one this gamma parameter
which is really big possibly is given to
you so based on this gamma you pick some
really small Epsilon net where the inner
products are much
sorry
marker
so pick some Epsilon net of this sphere
and only look at the values of your f
and g on those Epsilon net points and
based on that Define a continuous map on
the entire state right and then that
messes up some of these in a product
because things like close to the
boundary you might change the sign right
but it's fine you can just save them the
Epsilon to this really tiny right it's
um you can put another condition right
you can just there there are numbers
between gamma and one
okay so this is it for this question so
there are no question I'm going to
switch gears again to go to another
question
so good so I mean what kind of total
functions you might want to work with
one natural thing is
so just fill up all the stars with one
let's say
naturally I mean the same thing The
Continuous version it still has full
size right
but once you try to do the same for the
discrete version of it
what do you get
so the discrete version would correspond
to the following so I have the vectors
that are all like say normalized
these are all these X and y's and I put
some threshold here if everybody is
bigger than that threshold I put a plus
and everybody is
okay less than that threshold I put
minus so this is now total right
and
you can say well if I put the threshold
to be really close to one
so what let's say you put the threshold
this is
a number between
one and
let's say I don't even normalize this
for a second
so the inner product is between n and
zero
and let's say if I put here to be n
minus 2 this is like the simplest case
that's not just identity not just a
block of ones
this corresponds to the hypercute
problem so basically the question is if
I have ends strings and with strings and
I'm checking I put a plus if the
difference in Heming weight is exactly
one or less than or if they're equal and
I put minus if the Hamming distance is
at least two
this was conjectured in a previous paper
of puya Ahmed and the other people who I
don't remember their names
Diana oh okay
[Music]
um
that's this hypercube must have super
console sound right we don't know that
right
but um
but then you might say well it might
that might be too hard what if you just
try to make the threshold be smaller
what if the threshold maybe I don't know
it's something else
again minus square root 10 or n minus
some constant like login or something
it was good
okay sorry about that
um I mean it's to be fair I it wasn't
here so I
um
so but the issue is that in this one
then the gamma to Infinity is not
bounded anymore right so you really want
the separation to be for these bounded
gamma to Infinity
okay so no more questions
I mean yeah okay
so now switching to a different pair of
parameters another natural one to look
at is the the connection between
approximate gamma 2 and gamma 2.
foreign
showed that this approximate gamma 2
Norm is highly irrelevant because it
provides a really strong lower bond for
this public
bounded error randomness
and
because of this it's extremely important
in communication complexity
and uh
got my two Norm also corresponds if you
if you lower bound on approval lower
Bonds on the gamma 2 that gives you good
lower Bonds on some other models of
communication that are important that I
want to describe here
so these are crucial in communication
complexity
also yeah this notion of gamma two Norm
is a
type of factorization Norm that's well
known in Bannock space Theory apparently
and it initially was introduced by
lineal stripe and in communication
complexity and they brought it in have
used it to prove lower bonds
and so this question was phrased and
this greenhouse Ryman also in this
recent work of Petoskey
um Morgan and Abby schreiban that can
one substitute
this in this lower Bond can one
substitute actually this approximate by
just the exact gamma to an R this would
provide a wildly powerful method for
for a public randomness
but so what we showed was that we've
been Morgan and Ahmed we showed that
this is not possible
so
which recently showed that there is a
matrix whose public Randomness
communication is
logarithmic and the maximum possible so
log n is
you can always assume that it's the log
of that but this gamma-2 Norm is poly
and
so if you don't care about communication
complexity I'm just saying providing a
strong separation between approximate
gamma tuner and Gamma tunnel
so we give a matrix so there's
approximately or the only poly log
whoa
so this is capital n
okay so it's poly log n but it's gamma 2
is polyant
Okay so
I'll also just tell you what the
construction is
the construction is again another
variant of inner product turns out
everything is
in a product with some twist
so here the inner product function that
we're working with is the following
again I look at this integer points
between minus n and n
previously the in the previous
construction of the original
construction and the other question was
I put a plus if the sign is positive
right
but we prove that it's extremely hard
for randomized communication like it's
gamma to Infinity was almost maximal
right so if you want to use a randomized
protocol to solve that you really need
linear and like you need you can't beat
the trivial bound
but here it turns out that you you can
just check equality so I just want to
say if this inner product is either zero
or non-zero
so why is this so easy
why does it have some I can easily check
if this is true if it's zero or non-zero
well if you don't know communication
only I mean it doesn't make sense but
you can do mod pick a random Prime and
look at module that and exchange that
number and if it's zero it's going to be
zero with high probability here and it's
not it's not okay
um Okay so
this was
for three dimensional vectors a natural
thing
to ask is what can you reduce the
dimension by one what about two
dimensional like if this was a
two-dimensional question
there it's trivial basically it boils
down again to the identity function so
two dimensional inner product is the
same as identity
of a bigger Matrix
because you can say you just want to
check this condition
okay
I'll just uh put the same as this
and divide
you just so you have this is now just
checking if this
is equal to that so that just
corresponds to a identity Matrix where
the rows correspond to these things
right
so uh
they're approximately is constant but
the gamma 2 Norm itself is only poly
login so you can't say anything like
that
um
okay
so I'll now just describe some open
problems if there are no questions about
oh actually maybe one interesting thing
that people here might appreciate is
that how do we prove that this is hard
we want to give a strong lower bound on
the gamma 2 Norm of this
um basically the reason that this is
hard is because it contains
as a sub Matrix this tight example for
xamari Trotter so what's the tight
example for the memory tracker you have
this arrangement of this skewed grid
and then you look at the lines and look
at the incidences right
where the Rhymes don't Lions don't have
an extremely high slope
um and uh yeah basically we show that
the gamma-2 norm of this sub Matrix is
large
so if there requires a lot of work
because
one if one makes everything mod P it's
easy to prove lower bounds on the build
much more but on the other hand it's
approximate gamma Turner will also be
big
so you can use the spectral bounce to
get that but in the N integers it's more
work
yeah I won't describe more about the
detail
okay so now let's just discuss some open
problems there are many of these pair of
relations left so let's see which ones
are interesting
um so still the the question that the
separation we got was poly login versus
poly and for
approximate gamma 2 or gamma to Infinity
so can one get a constant versus poly n
okay so possibly this is doable but I
mean I'm not sure if it's true but
we only get it yeah so linear story
might show that it's cannot be too
ridiculous to separation to say if this
is constant you can't really this cannot
be larger than square root of 10. that
this doesn't refuse the possibility of
some polyan some other exponents
okay
so
another question that we already
discussed is for total matrices can you
obtain a separation between this gamma
to infinity and sine Rank and here all
I'm asking is that some Matrix with
constant gamma two Norm but super
constant sign rank
s so what I discussed was like poly log
versus poly and
for a constant okay yeah constant would
be just one versus
probably lock right
so this question is also interesting if
I make the gamma 2 Norm itself bounded
the exact damage does it imply that the
sun right must be found
so why is this interesting because
in this paper we are hundred and
which is the paper that mixed with the
other one is that they show that this
follows or Kayla crossover Building
Group this follows from this
quantitative strong bonds per Cohen's
identity
so basically it also follows
right any okay
Norm
gives an upper bound on sign rank but is
it true for arbitrary matrices
I mean the hope is like maybe you can if
I give you this extra condition you
might do something wildly smarter than
Johnson
foreign
and another relevant question that's not
about a pair of relations is about
another type of structure you want to
say pick any of these parameters if it's
constant can you find a big
monochromatic sub-rect angle
so this turns out to be an extremely
important problem for any choice of
these
parameters and the one that's uh I mean
the
weakest assumption is if I just say
gamma 2 Infinity is constant which
corresponds again to this randomized
public bounded protocols
can I find a dense monochromatic cell
breakdown by a rectangle I just mean a
sub Matrix so it's like a substitute of
the rows times the subset of the columns
where everything is either Plus
or all minus
I'm not sure who initially asked this
question
um
so I thought maybe in a paper of pitasi
and
Mika and
yeah I think they will a p versus NP
question piece of the NP is asked there
but maybe yeah
but anyways
so
yeah I didn't but for another related
question is if I just make sign rank to
be bounded can I find a big
monochromatic rectangle and this is the
result of alone parking Chastity or
doing chick sharir and also Fox Park
shook will give it uh who show that
and there's always a monochromatic
rectangle of density
at least this 2 to the minus sign rank
that's false then it settles the
relation
sign range
[Music]
right
yes yeah this the answer to this was
false then would also imply that
there is a matrix whose sign rank is
constant
yeah whatever just some something I
already said that they don't know
um Okay so
these
yeah I think that's it
but do you expect all of these should be
true
I
well I mean this one is natural and it's
true for Kayla glass why not for all my
extra stage
um
the total one I think it should be truly
even just for this High hurricane
Construction
thinking about it a lot but
and
this one yeah this one is also
interesting I mean people believe it
okay
[Laughter]
that's just like lack of examples oh
yeah that's a very good point yeah
exactly so the issue is in the entire
field that's literally we don't know any
other than this identity Matrix and this
hyper cue that's the only two examples
we know that has found in gamma to
Infinity
or maybe instead of like the threshold I
mean wait one Los Angeles to work
but other than these two we just don't
have any examples to work with so that
would be interesting to find some widely
new matrices that have done this camera
to make anything else
yes so I I think about noticing that to
tell me it just makes sense that like in
your partial matrices that you've used
yes
parameters there are they're a lot like
allele's graphs right the sort of
geometric I mean the sort of issue is
the same use of making points on SD
minus one and sort of keeping track of
like whether like the entries that are
that are specified in your Matrix I
think are basically the adjacency Matrix
of your gym at their graph and I guess I
just I mean since it's kind of my job to
like write a thing where I like all the
stuff that happened in the conference
and put it together like is there some
reason that these same kind of objects
come up for both of them so I mean again
I feel the difference with
this geometric graphs is there you embed
the graph so you embed vertices which
means you have only one map it's not a
bipartite concept right
so you can if I tell you embed this
independent set in a low dimensional
space you just can't do it right because
that means every pair Point has to have
any product that most at most zero right
but if I have the Matrix here all block
of minus one it has constant sign right
I just embed it in one dimension because
I can choose a map here and a map here
I just assign all of this here to
positive plus one assign everybody here
to minus one and everybody always has
been a product Microsoft right so it's a
wildly different concept
so yeah the complete bipartite graph
cannot be embedded in any Dimension I
mean any Dimension is full in fact it's
an interesting concept that I recently
learned about from Brandon that the
geometric yeah basically you just you're
given a graph what's the smallest
Dimension where you can embed it where
you look at it as a geometric graph so
it's this intersection of some spheres
and the Spheres can be arbitrary so
everybody has the same radius that you
uh that you're allowed to change the
radius of this year and there it's it's
known that complete bipartite graph it's
impacting
essentially the best this number of the
vertices basically but here is just not
right one
there's so much
any more questions
okay if not let's Bank copy again